[Musique]
je sais ça fait bizarre
les amis nous avons réussi il ya
quelques jours a récolté 57 mille euros
pour l'association c'est que du bonheur
totalement grâce à vous qui avez fait
une donation qui avait partagé laâyoune
qui avait contribué à cette maison d'une
autre jamais dit qu'ils ont dépassé les
50 mille je me rasais la tête en mode
mcfly c'est chose faite
attendez attendez attendez n'y at il
qu'une seule réalité ou une multitude de
réalités parallèles
peut-être que dans une autre réalité je
suis pas youtuber mais je suis boulanger
et que dans cette autre réalité je pense
que dans une autre réalité je suis
youtuber et par boulanger les amis la
vidéo sur les reptiliens vous avez
énormément plu nous allons aujourd'hui
parler de l'effet mandela connaissez
déjà peut-être c'est très connu c'est
fiona brume lors d'une conférence en
2010 qui découvre que nelson mandela
n'est pas mort en prison mais qu'il est
bel et bien toujours en vie ou
malheureusement au moment où je suis
cette vidéo il est décédé mais à
l'époque de la conférence non elle est
alors sur le cul elle demande aux gens
dans la salle s'il y en avait qui
pensaient comme elle qu'ils étaient
morts en prison est truqué la moitié de
la salle penser comme elle et l'autre
moitié savait qu'il n'était pas mort
elle a donc appelé ça l'effet mandela et
encore pour vous faire simple c'est
quand énormément d'individus ont un
souvenir qui ne correspond pas à la
réalité la réalité dans laquelle ils
sont parce qu'il a plusieurs réalités
joueurs appellent une dimension tout ça
il ya donc deux écoles les genres très
rationnel et très scientifique et les
gens qui aiment bien croire au fait
qu'on peut switcher d'une réalité à
l'autre sans même s'en rendre compte et
que du coup on a des souvenirs liés à
l'autre réalité alors alors un peu de
calme dans tout ça parce que là ça mais
le boucan dans vos cerveaux dernière
chose avant de commencer à checker les
effets mandela faut savoir que la
mémoire c'est quelque chose de très
complexe et que notre cerveau est loin
d'être parfait il a plein de bugs de
modifications qui se font compris dans
vos souvenirs vos souvenirs sont
modifiées des fois même vous avez des
souvenirs de choses qui ne sont en fait
jamais arrivé vous êtes approprié le
souvenir d'un autre ou alors vous l'avez
rêvé vous croyez que c'est vraiment
passé bref il ya mille explications
vis-à-vis de ça il ya beaucoup de
recherches qui sont faites autour de la
mémoire et c'est un truc assez
passionnant alors là vous pensez ce que
vous voulez être ça mais aujourd'hui ma
tuque et les effets mondiale
premièrement l'assassinât de jf kennedy
ils étaient six dans la voiture et
pourtant tout le monde a l'impression
qu'ils étaient 4 c'est très très vieux
et on s'en fout pas mal on apprend des
trucs plus actuelle qui nous parle un
peu plus la queue de pikachu c'est vrai
que dans mes souvenirs
elle a peut-être un bout noir mais dans
mes souvenirs très lointain et
bizarrement c'est toujours roulé à des
souvenirs très lointain ou alors des
souvenirs
notre réalité je n'ai pas conscience
d'avoir changé de réalité j'ai fait un
saut quantique ceux qui ont autour de 20
ans dans vos souvenirs et la boue noire
ou pas la queue de bigas luna mais voilà
qu'on se le dise pour moi je pensais
qu'elle avait le boule noire
effectivement mais en voyant ça je me
dis bah non c'est ce pikachu l'a
clairement le vrai ça c'est une sorte de
fake c'est comme les gens qui crèvent
squeeze avec un y à eu lieu sous un peu
des fakes je vois pas pk tu tous les
jours et je pense tout simplement que vu
que le bout de ses oreilles sont noirs à
ton cerveau a envie de voir le bout de
sa queue noire aussi parce que c'est
logique c'est parallèle ces voix là on a
un screen ici de la version jeune de
pokémon et on peut voir qu'il n'a pas de
boue noire au bout de la queue c'est pas
du tout le boudoir qu'on voit sur le
dessin d'abord un pokémon go et la palme
au noir non plus n'a hélas pas le bout
noir alors ce vieux pikachu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé là ma théorie je pense
juste que il à bout des oreilles noires
pikachu et que ton cerveau a envie de le
voir avec le bout de la queue noire
parce que c'est beau c'est homogène
c'est joli et moi je sais que j'adore
tout ce qui est trés parallèle tri
symétrique et donc mon cerveau a modifié
le souvenir comme ils l'avaient envie de
le modifier et ça a donné ça alors y'a
intrigue mauvaise genre dans un monde
parallèle tout est pareil mais ajuste
pikachu bout de sa queue il a un tout
noir ces gens ya juste ça comme
changement dans un monde parallèle
deuxième effet mandela apparemment le
bonhomme de monopoly n'aurait jamais eu
de monoï il est vrai que je l'imaginais
avec un monocle car peut-être dans une
autre réalité les concepteurs de
monopoly ils sont décidés à lui maître
mot nomme tout simplement j'ai une
théorie comme vous pouvez le voir le
bonhomme de monopoly à un costume un
chapeau je peux qu on appelait ça bref
c'est une tenue qui a vu plein de fois
dans plein de films dans plein de séries
le costard la can la moustache comme ça
et le monocle la vraie version des
bonhommes de monopoly c'est qu'il a tout
l'uniforme sauf le monop pour moi notre
cerveau a juste l'habitude d'un
stéréotype et il a appliqué ce
stéréotype aux mecs du logo de monopoly
que tu ne regardes pas tous les genres
impasse mi temps même quand tu prends
tout montpellier toulouse tu regarde
même pas le mec alors qu'il est juste
devant toi on en vient donc à la
question suivante le logone monopoly
n'at-il jamais une monocoque ou at-il un
monocle dans une autre réalité bon autre
mystère à la joconde est ce que dans vos
souvenirs la joconde souris ou est ce
qu'elle est une expression de neutre
parce que le fait est que la joconde
danse pas je compte ça elle a un très
léger sourire comme ça et apparemment
dans le souvenir de plein de gens elle
l'aurait une expression neutre sans
sourire pour ma part je l' ai toujours
vu sourire après peut-être que notre
réalité ne semblait pas du tout l'effet
mandela sa touche et l'histoire on l'a
vu avec l ai dit et aussi la culture des
paroles de musique qui changent dédié
look de films qui change et dans les
dialogues de films il ya le fameux dark
vador choix que c'est l'effet mandela le
plus connu et one le cash and ethics qui
est arrivé à ton père il m'a dit
[Musique]
il a dit que vous l'avez depuis non je
suis ton père il a jamais dit luc je
suis ton père mais alors pourquoi ce
qu'on vient d'une autre réalité bien
évidemment se souvient notre réalité
quand on raconte cette semaine à un pote
on l'a contextualise en dix ans luke je
suis ton père tu englobe tous les
éléments et juste avec cette phrase le
mec comprend le twist de star wars mark
hamill lui même a fait les plateaux télé
à mort après la sortie de star wars et
on lui demandait des fois de rejouer la
scène et il disait lui même luke je suis
ton père et non pas non je suis ton père
pour la raison que je viens de vous dire
mais donc ça a popularisé la phrase luke
je suis ton père et on en a même oublié
la vraie phrase qui a dans le film parce
que des gens qui disent look je suis ton
père maintenant raconte enfui en passant
est drôle y en a des masses c'est ma
théorie
après peut-être combien de notre réalité
dans laquelle dark vador des blues juste
ton père n'ont pas non je suis ton père
que dans cette réalité lucas le visage
de obi wan et obi-wan a le visage de
l'udc on remarque déjà la queue depuis
tout à l'heure on cite que des vieux
trucs bizarrement les faits mandela sait
jamais sur un truc qui date de l'ère six
mois c'est que sur des vieux trucs
vraiment ton cerveau a bien eu le temps
de modifier ton souvenir alors dans
blanche neige
on connaît tous la phrase miroir mon
beau miroir mais elle ne dit pas ça elle
dit en réalité oui
miroir miroir magique au mur mais que
c'est que ce bordel moi j'étais
persuadée qu'elle disait miroir mon beau
miroir alors pourquoi
et bien cela peut-être parce que miroir
magique au mur c'est beaucoup trop
d'éléments à retenir pendant quinze ans
après avoir vu cette scène que miroir
mon beau miroir bo est un mode qui
utilisent régulièrement si tu es beau
c'est beaucoup plus simple de retenir
miroir mon beau miroir que miroir
magique au mur ça sonne mal en plus là
on est juste victime de notre cerveau
qui nous joue des tours avec notre
mémoire à nos souvenirs et qu'ils aient
modifié voilà après il est vrai
peut-être que notre réalité
effectivement elle dit miroir mon beau
miroir et non pas de miroir magique au
mur nous ne savons parquet dans cette
autre réalité tout monde et sur
dailymotion et plus personne et sur
youtube ok je suis sur le forum de
reddit où ils ont fait un topic mandela
effect ou tous les gens témoignent de
trucs qu'ils pensent être des effets
modèle il ya la phrase très connus
d'apollo 13
houston we have problème
il ne dit pas houston on a un problème
il dit houston on a eu un problème donc
en anglais houston we've had prolonge
avons tant que français nous c'est la
même chose nous on utilise juste présent
pour nous ça veut tout dire yes to pay
as you go to the toy lot n a ici someone
venu à octobre voilà la page officielle
de la nasa propose les missions apollo
13 sites la phrase we've had problème un
peu après février 2007 la page aurait
changé pour afficher la nouvelle phrase
houston we have troubles et lovell qui a
dit cette phrase aurait dit lui même qui
l'a dit houston we have problème bon
j'avoue c'est là enfin nous on s'en bat
les couilles un peu quoi les looney
tunes sont apparemment tous on se
souviendrait de looney tunes
alors que c'est looney tunes sera écouté
je regardais et pour moi ça a toujours
été les miennes et unsa à temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non c'était bien looney tunes
effectivement peut-être que ça vient de
nos barons qui savait pas du tout parler
anglais et qui disait les looney tout tu
te mets devant les looney toons lucas
comme ça fait des années qu'on n'a pas
vu le générique on s'est dit ah ben
notre cerveau souvient claude ménara
disait tout parce qu'elle nous a dit
plus de fois tout ce qu'on a vu le logo
looney tunes et notre cerveau a modifié
le logo pour que cela corresponde à la
prononciation de notes d'argonne c'est
possible ou alors notre réalité
peut-être qu'il s'agit de lui mais tout
ne s'est pas tu ne t'y fictivement ya
aussi un effet mandela autour du film
iti vous souvenez itil extraterrestes
mois dernier je me situe pour jouer pour
ceux de ma génération on sait que
normand iti dans le film un moment il
dit iti téléphone maison l'extrait nous
montrent qu'en réalité il dit iti maison
téléphone voir ce qu'il en est et ita
mais c'est flippant mais quand on voit
ce que regardent et ghost est glauque
quand même
non non il dit it is téléphone maison
groix je me souviens bien par contre là
par contre c'est sûr tout le monde se
calme ne paniquez pas les enfants nés
dans les années 90 avaler sa place je
sais que votre coeur d'enfant là est en
train de s'emballer parce que vous êtes
révoltés parce que vous êtes en train de
voir attendait continue regarder la
scène peut-être que derrière ils
rétorquent les enfants y fifa voilà donc
effectivement ici il dit it is maison
téléphone mais à petite fille elle dit
il qui téléphonent maison elle rectifie
ce qu'il dit parce qu'ils partent vers
l'anglais parce que notre planète est
encore il apprend très vite et très fort
utile c'est plus logique
iti téléphone maison ton cerveau a plus
retenu cette phrase il a associé le
moment légendaires ou utilise m'a parlé
à ce que la petite fille a dit tout
simplement n'y a pas d'effets mandela
latin j'ai failli croire suite à cela
j'ai failli y croire je me suis dit
[ __ ] et tu mandela c'est incroyable et
bien les amis c'est la fin de cette
vidéo je n'ai toujours pas de cheveux
mais j'étais pas aller mais s'il vous a
plu je suis content de parler de l'effet
mandela parce que c'est un truc assez
puissant quand même c'est assez dingue
de se dire que autant de gens ont un
souvenir complètement différent de la
réalité et ils ont le même souvenir
l'hypothèse de dire que c'est un
souvenir d'une autre réalité et estives
et ça fait rêver tout parce qu'en plus
on sait qu'il ya plein de réalités
parallèles donc tu diras [ __ ] c'est
dingue mais en vrai j'ai quand même
l'impression qu'avec les exemples qu'on
a vu là en tout cas n'y a pas d'histoire
de souvenirs d'une autre réalité c'est
juste ton cerveau qui a été influencé
hier ou de l'autre en plus le fait que
ce soit que des vieux trucs tu ailles te
montrent que des trucs qui date d'il ya
très longtemps ou ton cerveau il a bien
eu le temps de modifier le souvenir de
le remanier j'aurais kiffé qu'il ya un
truc genre tu vois qu'il dote de six
mois genre à bas risque et jaune et qui
attend baril a jamais dit ça il a dit
quelque chose et jaune et qui attend et
là j'aurais fait quoi en tout cas ceux
qui y croient croyait et ceux qui n'y
croient pas et n'y croyez pas on s'en
fout mais bon voilà on aura des
cantiques et un peu stuc la casse
intéressante quand même je vous fais
plein de bisous j'étais assis vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me dire en commentaire
je garde mon chaîne vidéo portez vous
bien merci d'avoir gardé au revoir
[Musique]